hi leute ich mache dieses video gerade
im absoluten stress ist passiert im
moment so viel also ich und luca
befinden uns mitten in der aufnahme von
minecraft maus was ja morgen zum
allerersten mal auf lukas kanal kommt
ich stehe kurz davor 500.000 abonnenten
zu erreichen und ich finde es aber so
crazy also auf jeden fall schonmal
dankeschön an alle die mich abonniert
haben ist wird noch in 500 special
kommen ich habe mir für das special was
echt cooles überlegt was nicht so 08 15
ist es passiert viel kommen wir aber
einfach mal zum heutigen video das
heutige video nehme ich mit meinem
bruder sk lauf mit dem kam in den
letzten tagen nicht so viele aber er ist
heute freundlicher weise bei meinem
video dabei ich war heute extra
einkaufen für das video und zwar habe
ich dieses spiel hier gekauft bei face
heißt das und es ist relativ simpel in
der verpackung ist halt diese
konstruktion drin keine angst dass kein
place oder so ich fand es einfach
wirklich lustig und wir uns extra
einkaufen gefahren ihr könnt diese hand
hier einsparen da legt man sein gesicht
hier drauf du bist ein für kinder wie
man vielleicht sieht dann wird hier an
den seiten gedreht und wenn man pech hat
löst das ding aus und man kriegt was
halt jeweils auf dieser hand drauf ist
ins gesicht geschlagen und leute es ist
ihr denkt euch wahrscheinlich okay der
macht schon wieder ein video mit filou
aber wie gesagt ich bin halt einfach
mega im stress und blues halt einfach
das lustigste sag ich mal was ich da
sonst hätte ich noch schlagsahne extra
kaufen müssen oder so also das ganze
wird wieder mit blue gemacht das wird
halt einfach so ein kleines minispiel
video sage ich mal hier mit diesem
kleinen rat wird halb gedreht in dem
fall müsste jetzt derjenige der gedreht
hat fünfmal an dem ding hier drehen
ich glaub ich hab genug erklärt mein
bruder kommt jetzt jeden moment runter
und dann nehmen wir das ganze zusammen
auf leute ich mache jetzt gerade noch
mal ganz kurz dieses teile aber es ist
halt einfach für kindergesichter gemacht
ich weiß die video ist es kalt es ist
es geht also leute wirklich extreme
sebastians einigen voll kaputt und
fertig aber ich erkläre die spieler mal
ganz kurz drehscheibe wir drehen steht
auf 31 23
als gut muss man touristen aber dann
über gibst du russische volk angenommen
ich mach 5
nun kriegt die stelle nicht zu knapp vor
sebastian wir gleich duschen gehen ich
für meinen teil hab gleich dicke
aufnahme der hintergrund irgendwie
gesichert es wird ja alles kaputt gehen
es wird ziemlich krise er fängt an
eigentlich eigentlich ist es durch eine
challenge aber schon
wir müssen gut dann du fängst an und der
träger hier gehabt also einfach kinder
drauf kocht einigermaßen gerade halten
du musst jetzt dreht erst mal wie oft du
musst und fünf mal direkt das
allerschlimmste oh gott ich drücke die
daumen
nein eigentlich nicht das ist das wenn
ihr laptop ok herzlich willkommen jahr
2010 12 34 hat die lacher allerhöchste
leute und nein jetzt bin ich tragen
jetzt mich so was von rang okay ich
drehe dreimal es ist so ein richtiges
gefühl okay leute 1
h2o war das war viel zu schnell und ich
habe das gerade ausgetestet das war
niemals öfter als fünf mal ob du denn
modells jedes mal das ist einfach viel
zu spannend gerade ist es wirklich so
als eine revolver an die stirn halten
und abdrücken ich bin mir egal wie es
ein handtuch wohl für die hütte wird
dass wir die ganz einsam wie du es
tödlich deutsche gesellschaft für
forschung hier
du bist kannst du bist dann 12 an so
sieht man aus wenn man gerade eine
stelle bekommen hat leute aber es ist
noch sehr weit ratlos es nicht in den
augen nur auf der stirn danke dir dass
über teilgebiet für das tolle produkt wo
kommt man darf sich sauber machen weil
es dann einfach schlimmer ist nochmal
komplett dreckig zu werden und ich mache
es im nächsten rief ich werde okay ist
unter 2 das ist gerade mit mir geschehen
ich hab einfach ich habe selbst diesen
fetten haufen ist die richtige taktik
es macht so viel spaß weiter das ist ich
dachte mir als ich dieses spiel gekauft
hab ich dachte okay du machst ein video
damit da wird's lustig aber ich dachte
mir wer in dieser welt gibt 15 euro
gewährt das gekostet für so ein spiel
aus wo man einfach nur entweder dreckig
wird oder nicht aber im video und so
macht einfach viel zu viel fand fischer
es ist so ein trauma von diesem ding
getroffen zu erneuern
diese werden ins auge gericht
okay leute wir machen jetzt allmählich
immer ein bisschen mehr ist die
behinderte idee aller zeiten ich habe
diese übrigens bei twin tv gesehen da
haben wir erst mal gebraucht aber nur so
für so ein mini dinge ich darf mir
eigentlich kann man daraus mein ganzes
video machen einfach was vor spannendes
ok ich hab keinen abbekommen ist als
erstes man dann waren du von deinen
kampf auf
und 5 ich habe gerade zwei gemachten
habs direkt bekommen voll crazy oft
nicht zweimal gedreht sondern 53 mal
gedreht einmal fünf einmal die danke
berlin
und 18 es ist schrecklich 12345 nein
nein leute ich hatte echt gedacht dass
sebastian abbekommt und richtig hatte
wieder den video haufen pofalla jetzt
wird jetzt wenigste was man dran es in
meinen nerven keine 2002
dazu zählen ich bin muss ich auch noch
zwischen den augen aber falls sie jetzt
mal dran seid dann schreib mal wie du in
die kommentare
einfach weil wie du bist so macht man
das alter babys beauty palace wenn du
das gerade siehst du dich ich habe ihn
wieder springen video gesagt dass wir
alle diese produkte die du hast zu
schicken sonst was hast du gemacht nicht
ich weiß dass ich merke mir das wenn wir
jetzt wieder sehen wird bitte baby
schick mir welche ich finde das wirklich
einfach nur eklig
es riecht nach kindheitstrauma das hier
ist jetzt das semifinale dafür dafür
können wir uns mal aber gleich wird
komplett krise wo gott leute das sieht
vielleicht nicht so viel aus wie bisher
aber es ist mehr denn je weiß ich mich
dass ich jetzt raus bringen jetzt müssen
wir gern duschen gibt veganer autoreifen
sonst wird sie kaufen
jedoch würde ich schon dass man das noch
mal ich will mir auch jedoch dann lassen
sich hat ihm auch einmal so
so ein fell gehabt ist okay ich ziehe
das 3 1 und 2
gleich kommt das große finale leute
bleibt unbedingt dran dann wird die
komplette flasche leer gemacht
ich will nach vier mann des tages
mein gott so oft du bist noch nie gab
dreimal drehen das ist ja crazy
wir haben jetzt sechs schon weg aber
okay das ist ein 44 leute robert 23
diesmal hielt er ihn auf solche
führungen im hohen bogen darüber wie
geht es dir so etwas sagen es ist das
bescheuerte video site youtube aber ich
sagte es sind jedes video vielleicht
sollte irgendwie mal mein content über
dingen so leute wir machen das jetzt
noch einmal jetzt kommt das fucking
finale es wird so krank jetzt jetzt
gehts all-in leute
mein gott das wird so krise kommt sie
einfach nur fünf welt die sache
diskutiert was machst du denn junge mann
und ich hörte er habe durch die nasa
muss die automatische seien deutlich
müssen wirklich wichtigeres im sinn
neben ich bin das liest massa hatte
polens die es lieber ich weiß dass auch
die video schmeckt vorzüglich harrislee
es war so schwer die letzte bombe das
einfach fast nichts in meinem sich
gekommen ist und du drückst einfach noch
mal richtig glauben
die musste heute wissen sie es dabei ich
nehme euch das video jetzt ganz schnell
hier könnt ihr mich gerne abonnieren sie
das nicht getan haben ich bin
unmittelbar von 500.000 abos also es
wäre echt mega mega verpfändet und hier
oben gibt es mein letztes video dann
danke dass du dabei warst für das finale
geben und wir sind man diesmal wieder
tschüss